>> It's gonna be a lot of fun.
>> Four and a half hours, four
and a half hours.
>> You've often said this like
a telethon with no --
>> I didn't know to mention.
That >> I stole that line.
>> Yes.
Unit >> At one point, that's
why I bring it up.
We've got a lot of fun guest,
Henry Winkler, who I've been
obsessed with since a.
>> We've been --
>> Jeremy --
is going to be here.
John Maher is joining us from
Tokyo, Japan.
Have you ever heard of Tokyo,
Japan?
>> I have, I have.
>> And Patty Labelle, who I
think has been with us almost
every year.
>> Yes, we love to see her.
>> And every year she has more
and more people in her house.
It's an incredible gathering of
people.
>> Guess what, the first year
we don't do this, we're going
to miss Patty's house.
>> I would love.
That >> On the rise of command,
we've got Amy said heiress,
Brigitte Everett, --
and --
we've got a lot of fun.
>> It's a lot of.
Fun >> Very excited about
tonight.
>> Yeah, it's a night of
traditions, of course.
And yet, we are excited, we are
excited.
>> Speaking of traditions, it
is, it is just the top of the
hour.
>> Right, top of the hour.
>> And so we have been here for
seven years doing this.
And for most of those years.
>> Are you asking about alcohol?
>> While at the top of the hour,
we typically have a toast.
And elhat, I'm here from
a lot of people, and ISS
I'm just wondering, does daddy
get his juice?
[Laughter]
>> Can daddy get his juice
responsibly?
>> Of course, always.
>> Well to be, honest I did not,
I did not bring any beer.
>> You don't bring anything?
>> Absolutely not.
>> Well Anderson, this is why I
am a really good partner to
you.
I've got it.
>> Okay.
>> We are doing this.
>> How did this tradition
begins again?
>> Just, I came and I joined
the show and I was like, we've
got to do shots.
Okay, so here we go.
>> So what are the rules?
Here >> The rules are that we
are going to do a toast, at the
top of every hour.
You at home are hanging out
with us, and we want to toast
with you to the top of every
hour, with whatever you feel
comfortable toasting with.
Orange juice, whatever, this is
a communal experience, all of
us together.
We realize we are just
wallpaper on your television
for the next five hours, and we
are cool with that.
>> But at the top, we want you
to lean in and say, --
>> With a jacket like, that is
hard to do wallpaper.
>> All right.
Well, you have nice things to
say about it earlier.
>> Well no, I just it's.
>> It's okay well, I can't
really --
>> The funny thing as you all
need to know, Anderson really
does not drink.
>> I don't drink.
>> And so I think now Colbert
made us do a shot a couple of
weeks ago, but I think that
this may be kind of the first
tequila he's had since two
years ago.
>> Two years ago, yes, that's
true.
>> Anderson, love you so much,
thank you for having me.
Cheers everyone, happy new
year.
Here we go.
>> Good right?
>> Okay.
>> I feel loosened up already.
You good?
>> Yeah.
>> So how were your holidays?
>> Andy and I, we both have
kids, we've got a few kids.
So for us, this holiday season
was like, you really can't --
get >> It worse than the pick
up juice?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't understand why
people do this.
>> Well you're going to
understand a little bit, maybe.
>> By the way, we had a lovely
played eight.
Today >> We did, yes.
>> His kids come over to my
house.
And I should mention all of our
kids I know at the top of the
hour, are watching us right
now.
So will you all indulge me.
Hey, hi.
>> This is the first year that
my son Wyatt, who is three and
a half, a year before and April,
understood who Santa was, and
got excited about Santa.
So, it was such an exciting
Christmas for that reason.
And Santa, we I wanted to leave
him m&ms, a banana, and a
protein bar and milk.
And Santa ate all of.
Those >> Are really, he ate the
protein?
Barn >> Well >> He is telling
anyone who will listen that we
are jewish, and Santa does not
come to our health.
>> Really?
>> Yes, he knows, he knows.
>> Did you tell him that,.
>> That were jewish?
>> That Santa doesn't come?
>> No, he kind of put the
pieces together there.
He's like, okay.
>> You are in Paris over
Christmas.
>> Yes, I want to Paris over
Christmas, which my partner in
parenthood, Ben, his family's
French, so my kids are speaking
French.
And so they all went, and we
all went, and they were all
speaking French, the kids.
I don't know what they're
talking about.
>> So you haven't in all the
years he has picked up any
French, I mean I can say a
little, bit but I'm just going
to, the thing that drives me
nuts about France's for our
French viewers, they don't know
what ice coffee is.
>> So any place you go, they
don't know what ice is period.
>> They do not, but literally I
will go into every café and ask
for an ice coffee, and they
would look at me as if I was
the first person in the world
who has ever even mentioned
that there is such a thing as
black coffee with ice.
>> Listen, I am an ice queen, I
order ice everywhere I go, and
nobody wants to bring the ice,
what can I tell.
You >> I brought some with me
today.
>> Didn't Madonna recently just
call you a queen?
>> A troublemaker.
>> A troublemaking queen.
>> Yes, she said that from the
stage at --
the you know, what if the shoe
fits.
[Laughter]
What can I say?
You are a thoroughbred parent
though.
This guy will be, like I'll say
oh where you're going for the
break, you both have time off
at the same time.
He'll say oh, we're looking at
Morocco, or you went to
Colombia or, yeah.
I'm taking my kids to Florida
this week, and you would think
we're going to Australia.
I mean, you are very bright
pair.
>> Yeah, I did have one of
those, I was the person on the
plane with the child who was
screaming in the middle of the
night, we were in Brazil and
flying back.
And literally at one point like,
this is our, it's a ten hour
flight, two hours into it
Sebastian who have been
sleeping on, because he's too
little have a seat of his own,
he wakes up.
And for the next eight hours.
>> I want to sleep on you?
>> What.
>> For the last eight hours, he
was the kid who was screaming.
At one point in mid screen, the
flight attendant came over and
said, do you think he would
like a fruit plate?
>> I was like, I don't think
he'd like a fruit plate, no I
don't know what he wants, but I
think it's a fruit plate.
>> But they were very sweet,
all of the flight attendants
were lovely.
>> Did that shock make you cry?
>> Like your ice water.
Oh my god.
>> Yeah.
>> So you are at this thing,
the jingle ball.
>> I was, I was introducing
share.
Who by the way has had a number
one hit every decade, oh this
is what your taunting.
>> So you've got criticize for
what you were wearing.
I did, I cannot believe you are
showing that on camera.
>> Oh sweetie, can we just show
the picture again.
>> I don't know if we can do a
script --
aren't you wearing the same
shoes.
>> No, I'm wearing the same
shoes, and there's nothing
wrong with these shoes.
>> Well yet, if you're a kid,
as you said your 55 years old.
>> Okay, okay, I love my shirt
that's an Alex --
>> I heard a comedian say that
you are trying to appeal to
your, to relate to your step
son with that.
Which I think is kind of funny.
>> Well I look like a lesbian
toddler, it's true, but I love
my Alex mills shirt, it's a
great shirt, I think I should
have tried the half tuck but,
thank you for humiliating me.
>> I feel like by tonight, I
look like Logan Ryan, and he
looks like --
I feel like you know what,
there is a slight feeling of
you just like, trying to, go
for it.
>> Yeah, you feel a little like
Logan --
>> My son right now is ex is
obsessed with mandates.
I don't know for you, who are
kids.
And a lot of kids who are
watching to, if you have kids.
I don't know if your kids are
also obsessed with mandates,
idolized band-aids and stickers
were such a thing.
>> That's why it's --
a >> Lags, which I rarely show
because I feel like.
Well there's a couple of
stickers, but there's like, the
most he's had like 14 band-aids
on his legs at one time.
Which, I can't have him wear
short pants, because I feel
like people will think that I'm
--
I'm abusing him in some way.
I'm a terrible parent.
>> Ben isn't a moment right now
where he thinks everyone with
gray hair except me, are my
parents, --
his grandparents came in with a
picture of Andy Warhol the
other day he goes, this is
mama.
I'm like that's Andy Warhol
dude, that's not mama.
>> That's so relate-able.
That such a really double story,
every kid does that with their
Andy Warhol --
>> [Laughter]
Listen you do not want to start
with me, ten minutes into the
show, about relate-able,
Vanderbilt boyer.
Oh my god, we are off and
running a, this shot really
may.
You know what, euro, you are a
troublemaker [laughter]
.
>> Also my son lost, he lost
his bare.
>> Yes, you made a plea on live
--
with >> And mark and Kelly's
Jeanne's staff, and live
viewers tracked down the bear
that was lost, just known as
bear.
And that's also bear.
But it disappeared, and then of
course live viewers found two
of them on epsie, won an
Australian, one in --
I got them both on >> --
so there's two replacements.
But then we found it.
>> No, no interest in
replacements.
But then we found the original
one, because of course it was
right out of the car seat in
the front seat, we're of course
it would have been.
And I thought people would look,